hey guys
Greg Alva here Stacey Oh Howard you guys
can follow her Instagram and Twitter
Stacy do you like Thomas the cruise I do
like Thomas the Toolman cruise he's
great we're gonna watch this video from
Mission Impossible fall out called halo
jump stunts behind the scenes it's crazy
stunts the craziest stunts apparently
he's ever done and we're gonna get it
all ruined for us right now from
Paramount Pictures but hey before doing
that Stacy's here with me today because
we are wanting to get the word out the
real rejects are gonna be hosting an
event at arena Center lounge the theatre
that stacy is the janitor for the new
javascript an event coordinator over
there it's this cool little theater but
really really cool theater actually
we've been there a couple of times now
but it's gonna be on July 7 it's gonna
be a fun event where we can have
subscribers come out if you're a fan of
the channel whatever come out and we're
gonna like do some interesting
interactive stuff with the audience it's
gonna be a chance for us to get to know
you guys you'll get to know us on a
better level will be screening some
stuff July 7th book market if you live
in LA it's on Sunset Boulevard it's
gonna be fun indeed so you can get
tickets at arena screen com
let's do this Stace Howard all right
Greg
that crazy halo jump just a sequence Tom
and I have been talking about for a
number of years Tom will be the first
actor to do a halo jump on camera halo
jump this high altitude low open
military jump at 25,000 feet open the
chute below mm and sneak into the
foreign country without being detected
that's the idea of halo sound like crazy
numbers there's a lot of risks in going
to 25,000 feet the audience seem to know
something's being cheated it's not it's
important to be doing it all for real
there's dangers of hypoxia and the bends
you start losing your mind but you don't
realize it we had to develop really dill
do this that is both a prop and a
life-saving device the first phase of
the Hello sequence was building a wind
machine that was large enough for us to
be able to rehearse so we built one of
the world's largest winters
it would require over a hundred jumps to
get the scene we needed the UAE and had
they not stepped in we would not have
been able to accomplish the sequence
we've been doing five jumps a day onto
an honor
noone will do three c-17 jump and it's
challenging
we're shooting in nighttime sequence and
light has to be perfect
we're gonna get one shot today she has
one shot a day three minutes every day
to get the shot Wow I can't just get on
the plane and go you have to spend 20
minutes on the ground breathing pure
oxygen so that you don't get
decompression sickness the plane has to
climb to 25,000 feet all of the lighting
turns from white to red you're talking
about Tom jumping out of a plane that's
traveling at 165 miles an hour
[Music]
know who's out of the trailer yeah he's
the position himself so that he lands
exactly three feet away from the camp oh
he's very concerned there's only the
ticking clock and filming a movie but
it's not usually the earth flying
towards you
this is one stunt yeah that's just the
biggest one I mean that's the big sell
so they have to show us that to be like
come see this movie even if they hadn't
showed it up - we didn't seat
I love the flip of that the last big
stunt was he's hanging off the side of a
plane and this time it's like what if
you're falling all the people in the
lighting in all the films everything has
to be perfect probably $200,000 every
time I remember seeing that shot in the
trailer and I was thinking whoa is he
really I didn't hear anything about that
stuff yeah so I saw I was like that
doesn't look like a green-screen it
looks like he's really doing it and they
show it here this guy is just insane
they could have green-screen this and it
would have been fine obviously because I
still had to question whether or not it
was a green-screen
that's insane how they're just getting a
stunt double they had to spend millions
extra to build a crazy win machine but
that's good on the production company
that's good on paramount because they
know a big part of the selling point
with especially with the latest
installments of Mission Impossible is
Tom Cruise does his own stunts so even
if have to and he's like 75 years old
now he's not even buddy's doing anymore
it's like what other movie would they go
yeah we'll spend millions of extra
dollars for you to learn how to do this
stunt and we'll build some crazy
contraption just so you can do this
stunt no other star would get that but
they know that Tom Cruise a big selling
point is they want to know it's him
actually doing it and that'll put people
in the seats it's kind of gnarly looking
back on how a few years ago we were all
look the Tom Cruise careers dead yeah
so told you and then to see him now any
like oh man he's like one of the best
right now my pants this is at the top if
you see the trailers this is my most
anticipated movie of the summer because
there's multiple sequences multiple of
moments that are just look amazing in
the film I think this will be the best
summer movie for sure I agree I am also
really excited to see Henry Cavill not
as Superman in another film cuz I like
him I think he's been not given the
proper chances to show off what he could
be absolutely so this is that
opportunity where I'm like okay maybe
this is the one cuz like I really liked
him and Man From UNCLE
I loved him on the tutors back in the
day I'm watching that show right now
actually it's very sexy in it I want to
see him and something that's not
associated with the DC Universe and this
is impossible this is gonna be an orgasm
fester the room your sound is like
authentic mine sounded like sad you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification it's not a video is
Stacy unless there's one section click
that notification bell Stacy Oh Howard
on Instagram and Twitter follow her
there for the erotic photo she posts on
there and the erotic tweets arena
cinemas calm go check out that theater
July 7 to keep your calendar open for
that Saturday 5:00 in the morning the
event will go till from 5:00 to 5:30
perfect half hour slot yeah looking
forward to it guys